[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
مع الشداد المعارك موسكو تجد صعوبات على
المحور الغربي لباخمت والاوكرانيون يرفضون
الانسحاب
حول تفتيش منشاتها النوويه ونتنياهو يهاجم
جراس بعد رفضه الخيار العسكري
مواجهه عنيفه في اثينا بين الشرطه
والمتظاهرين احتجاجا على حادث القطار
ورئيس الوزراء يطلب الصفح
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
نبدا نشرتنا من تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا
وبالتحديد من بخموت في الشرق حيث تظهر
المؤشرات ان المدينه على شفا السقوط رغم
نفي اوكراني لروايه الروس
وفي هذه الاثناء اشار مراسل العربيه الى
ان القوات الروسيه تحاصر بخمد بالكامل
لكنها تواجه صعوبه في المحور الغربي فيما
تتمسك القوات الاوكرانيه بمواقعها وترفض
الانسحاب وقد اعلنت هيئه الاركان في الجيش
الاوكراني التصدي لاكثر من 130 هجوما
روسيا على مدار ال24 ساعه الماضيه في
اتجاهات كوبيانسك ولمانسك وباخمد وبقيه
محاور دونتس وقد قال الجيش الاوكراني ان
القوات الروسيه لا تتوقف عن محاولاتها
لحصار بخموت بينما تظهر الوحدات
الاوكرانيه مقاومه شرسه وقد اتهمت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه القوات الروسيه
باستخدام المدنيين في خرسون دروعا بشريه
بعد نشر مضادات جويه بين المباني السكنيه
الروايه الاوكرانيه حول الوضع في الشرق
تعززها وزاره الدفاع الروسيه التي اكدت
استمرار الضربات الجويه ونيران المدفعيه
في استهداف مواقع الجيش الاوكراني في
دونتس واشارت الوزاره في بيانها الى اسقاط
اثنتي عشره طائره مسيره اوكرانيه واعتراض
سته صواريخ خلال العمليه
واضافت ان قواتها استهدفت مقر قياده كتيبه
ازوف فيزا ودمرت مخزن اسلحه اوكراني في
وبينما تشتد المواجهات قال جنود اوكرانيون
على خط التماس بدونيتس انهم يتمسكون
بمواقعهم ويكبدون القوات الروسيه خسائر
باستخدام المعدات الغربيه مثل قذائف
الهاون الفرنسيه في الصنع
الان اصبح الامر اسهل بكثير من قبل قد
تحولت قواتهم الرئيسيه الى لكن في بعض
الاحيان يحاول العدو الاعتداء على مواقعنا
في مجموعات صغيره بالمدفعيه عده مرات نحن
نعرف اهدافنا مجموعات المشاه وقاذفات
القنابل الاليه وقذائف الهاون طائراتنا
مسيره تكشفها ونستخدم الاحداثيات للتصويب
واطلاق النار
الان حيث مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر يتابع
الاوضاع عن كتب رائد اهلا وسهلا بك اخر
المعلومات الوارده عن معركه بخموت وهل
تحولت بخموت الى ازوف ستال جديده رائد ام
لا يمكن قول ذلك
ما زالت مستعصيه حتى الان لكن منذ عده
ساعه فقط معلومه نريدها منك يعني في في
لقط انه جرى اخراج جميع المدنيين من بخموت
هل هذا الكلام صحيح ام لا مازال هنالك
مدنيون
هذه المعلومه بالذات لا بد من الاشاره الى
ان المدنيين تقريبا غير موجودين على الارض
منذ فتره فقط يعني المقاتلين هم من يكونون
الا من كانوا في بعض الملاجئ اليوم انا
يعني استمعت لاحد
المتحدثين من الجنود
الروس الذين يقاتلون في باخ متقال بان
يعني الاتهامات التي يواجهها الجيش
الاوكراني بان يعني روسيا تستخدم
المواطنين كدروع بشريه قال بان هذا هو
العكس بالضبط يختبئون في المنازل وعندما
نقتحم البنايه او المنزل يخرجون لنا
المدنيين كوجه
لايقافنا عن القتال او الضربات او يعني
القصف بالفعل هناك لغط كبير في هذا جانب
لكن الجانب الروسي اول مقاتلين وبشكل شخصي
يعني انا استمعت منهم يقولون بانهم يصدرون
المواطنين للمواجهه قبل ان يعني يواجهوا
الجيش الروسي الفعل المحور الغربي طالب لا
بد من التعريف المتلقي هنا اسمح لي طالب
هناك معلومات عن انسحاب تدريجي من مدينه
خروما وهذه المدينه
هي او البلده في المحور الغربي التي تقدم
اليها جيش الروسي قوات باغنر من الناحيه
الشماليه نحو الغرب وهي الطريق الوحيد
القريب على طريق
بلده كراسنا هناك انسحاب تدريجي على شكل
مجموعات صغيره من الجيش الاوكراني الى
الطريق السريع للذهاب الى
القدر لكن هناك انسحاب تدريجي ساكتفي بهذا
القدر منذ مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر شكرا
جزيلا لك رائد على كل هذه المتابعه
ومع دخول الحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا عامها
الثاني لم تحسم روسيا المعركه عبر الجو
حتى الان رغم تفوقها على اوكرانيا من حيث
القدرات الجويه وعدد الطائرات وبحسب صحيفه
التايمز البريطانيه فان الفضل يعود الى
صواريخ ارض جو المعروفه باسم سام والتي
تستخدم تكنولوجيا الرادار لتحديد
التهديدات ووفق محللين في الشؤون الدفاعيه
تشهد اوكرانيا معركه ارض جو وليس معركه جو
جو حيث تدافع اوكرانيا عن سمائها من الارض
وقد ابقت اوكرانيا صواريخ سام باستمرار في
حاله حركه ما قود قدره الروس على تدميرها
الى حد كبير وهذا الامر يجبر القوات
الجويه الروسيه على الطيران على ارتفاعات
منخفضه لجعل صواريخ سام اقل فاعليه
مراحل الحرب الجويه في اوكرانيا في فبراير
عام 2022 بدات العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
بضربات جويه على جميع انحاء اوكرانيا
امتدت الحرب الجويه منذ بدء الحرب حتى
نهايه ابريل عام 2022 حيث كثفت طيران
الروسي من قصفه كما نفذت روسيا 200 طلعه
جويه يوميا في شهرها الاول من الحرب
مقارنه بخمس الى عشر طلعات جويه نفذتها
اوكرانيا وبحلول نهايه الربيع العام
الماضي تغيرت طبيعه الحرب الجويه وتركزت
المواجهات في الشرق في ابريل من عام 2022
تخلى الروس عن طلعات جويه تخترق الخطوط
الاماميه اما في سبتمبر عام 2022
تغيرت معركه السماء مره اخرى بعدما اشترت
روسيا مسيرات ايرانيه رخيصه واستخدم الروس
المسيرات طوال شهر اكتوبر الماضي لضرب
البنيه التحتيه للطاقه باوكرانيا دابت
اوكرانيا على مطالبه حلفائها بارسال
مقاتلات حديثه بما في ذلك طائرات تي اف 16
الى الرياض الان لمزيد من المتابعه
والتحليل معي من هناك العميد الطيار اسعد
عوض الزعبي المحلي العسكري عميد اسعد اهلا
وسهلا بك هل فعلا اداء سلاح الجو الروسي
غير فعال او بطيء ام لا كل هذا الكلام جزء
من البروباجاندا الغربيه ضد موسم
مساء الخير يعني كما ذكرتم بتقرير يكون لا
شك ان الفجوه كبيره جدا بين القدرات
القتاليه او الامكانيه القتاليه ما بين
روسيا واوكرانيا رغم ان السلاح هو واحد
يعني سواء بين سلاح الجو او سلاح الدفاع
الجوي فهو واحد وكان من المفترض يعني
كتقدير الخبراء انه ان تستطيع روسيا حقيقه
يعني تدمير القوى الجويه الاوكرانيه
والدفاع الجوي ومقرات القياده الخاصه بها
خلال الضربه الاولى لان روسيا نفذت عمليه
جويه لمده ثلاث ايام تخللت حوالي 11 ضربه
جويه كثيفه وبالمناسبه يعني بتحليل
الطيران من المفترض هذه الضربات ان تنهي
كليا القوى الجويه الاوكرانيه لكن يعني
فوجئ الجميع حقيقه ان روسيا خسرت كانت
خساره بالمقاتلات ما يعادل ربما يزيد عن
130 مقاتلا من الطائرات الطائرات الجيل
الثالث والرابع وكذلك ايضا هناك اكثر من
200 حوامه و200 حوامه او المروحيه كانت
بسبب ان روسيا زجت هذه الحوامات وخاصه
حوامات الاقتحام او حوامات الدعم الناري
زجاجتها بشكل كبير باتجاه كيف وفوجئت هذه
المروحيات بوجود كماء
من وسط الدفاع الجوي كماء المتحركه والتي
تحمل على كتف من صواريخ اجلا او من صواريخ
كوبرا وحتى بمراحل متاخره اصبحت صواريخ
السنجر وبالتالي تعرضت مروحيات الروسيه
لكثير من الخسائر وهذا في يعني في الايام
التاليه او في الاشهر التاليه دفع روسيا
الى استخدام مسيرات باعتبار مسيره حجم اقل
والبصمه الراداريه لها قليله وكان ايضا
يعود كما ذكرتم في تقرير لكم ان رادارات
الصواريخ سواء صواريخ البعيده المدى سام
خمسه او المتوسطه البتشورا او حتى القريبه
والقصيره لها يعني اجهزه
جيد بس يعني بعض التحاليل العسكريه خصوصا
بعد الدراسات العسكريه التي نقراها تقول
ان الروس لم يستخدموا سوى 10 الى 15% من
قوتهم الجويه الناريه يعني لم تزج موسكو
بطائراتها الحديثه من الجيل الخامس ولا
بصواريخها الفرد صوتيه وهذا وهون ربما
يعني في اطار استراتيجيه تدحرج المعركه
لماذا برايك
يعني لا شك يعني ما يتحدث انهم لا يسجوا
اكثر من عشره او عشرين ميه يكفي ان نقول
ان روسيا زجت يعني
وزجت المقاتلات القاذفات الاستراتيجيه
ممنوع تبوليف 165 وهذا يشير تماما الى ان
يعني لا تزج هذه القاذفات الاستراتيجيه
باك فاير الا في حال يعني عدم وجود نتائج
حقيقيه او نتائج مرضيه من قبل الطائرات
المقاتلات او المقاتلات القذفه التي
استخدمت في بدايات وخاصه سخوي 25 سوقيه 34
اذا يجب القول الحقيقه ان هناك الكثير من
خساره الروسيه وزجت روسيا يكفي ان نقول
انها نفذت عمليه جويه تخللها عديد عدد
كبير من الضربات الكثيفه ضربات كثيفه
بقوام لا اقل من 70 الى 80 طائره لذلك
يعني اعتقد ان هناك في مبالغه حقيقه بهذا
الكلام لكن روسيا خسرت والدليل ان يعني
استندت مؤخرا
لانها بنيت بخسائر كبيره جدا كان من
المفترض ان تحقق ان تحقق موسى بتفوقها
الجوي ان تحقق يعني على الاقل
لا نقول السيطره استراتيجيه انما سيطره
تكتيكيه لكن حتى هذه السيطره تكفيه لم
تستطيع ان تحققها وهذا ما دفعها حقيقه ان
استلام الطيران المسير او استخدام القذفات
الاستراتيجيه
وصواريخ حتى صواريخ فرط صوتيه ساكتفي بهذا
القدر من الرياض العميد الطير اسعد عوض
الزعبي المحلي العسكري شكرا جزيلا لك على
هذه المشاركه
الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
ازمه تسمم تلميذات ايرانيات تتصاعد وسلطات
تقول انها ستحاسب المسؤولين مع زياده
الغضب الشعبي
اهلا بكم من جديد نستكمل نشرتنا من تطورات
الملف النووي الايراني حيث قال رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي
ان تصريحات رئيس الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رافائي غير جديره به لانه شخص
مسؤول وتسائل نتنياهو قائلا لماذا اعتبر
جروسي ان اي هجوم عسكريه على المنشات
النوويه الايرانيه امر محظور مؤكدا ان نهج
الدبلوماسيه مع طهران على وشك الموت
المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه رفاهيل روسي
اعلن في طهران ان الهجوم الاسرائيليه على
المنشات النوويه خارج عن القانون خارج عن
اي قانون بالنسبه لشخص مسؤول مثل جروسي هل
يجوز لايران التي تدعو بصراحه ووضوح الى
تدميرنا وان تحضر الادوات لقتلنا من
الواضح انه مسموح لنا بالدفاع عن انفسنا
جاءت في اعقاب تصريحات اخرى من طهران تشير
الى تفاقم الازمه مع الغرب بشان برنامجها
النووي فالخلافات الايرانيه الغربيه لم
تحسمها زياره جروس الاخيره الى طهران رغم
تصريحاته التي بدت متفائله فبعد ساعات
قليله من زياره جروسي خرجت منظمه الطاقه
الذريه الايرانيه لتنفيه التوصل الى اي
اتفاق على تركيب كاميرات جديده في المنشات
النوويه الايرانيه
اجهزه المراقبه هذه كان قد تم وضعها بموجب
الاتفاق النووي لعام 2015
لكنها ازيلت العام الماضي كنتيجه الانهيار
الاتفاق في اعقاب انسحاب واشنطن منه عام
2018 في عهد الرئيس ترامب وقال المتحدث
باسم المنظمه الايرانيه بهروس كمالوندي
انه لم يحدث اي نقاش او اتفاق مع وفد
مفتشي الوكاله الدوليه لتركيب هذه
الكاميرا
التصريحات الايرانيه تتعارض مع ما اكده
جروسسي بعد عودته من طهران مباشره والتي
قال فيها انه توصل الى اختراق يتعلق
بموافقه ايران على اعاده تشغيل كاميرات
مراقبه في عده مواقع نوويه وزياده وتيره
عمليات التفتيش
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه قالت ان
ايران قدمت تطمينات بانها ستتعاون اخيرا
في تحقيق متعثر بالفعل بشان جزيئيات
اليورانيوم التي عثر عليها في مواقع غير
معلنه فضلا عن اعاده تركيب اجهزه المراقبه
التي ازيلت وقد اصدرت الوكاله وايران
بيانا مشتركا لدى عوده جروس من زيارته قبل
يومين فقط من اجتماع ربع سنوي لمجلس
محافظي الوكاله المؤلف من 35 دوله وقال
دبلوماسيون ان البيانه خاض في القليل من
التفاصيل لكن احتمال حدوث تحسن ملحوظ في
العلاقات بين الجانبين من المرجح ان يحول
دون مسعا غربي لقرار اخر يطلب من ايران
التعاون
ومع ذلك زياره جروس يبدو انها لم تحدث اي
اختراق مهم فئران قدمت وعودا مماثلا من
قبل لكنها لن تتمخض عن اي شيء يذكر
التعهدات التي اكدها جروسسي وسارع الطهران
لنفها تاتي بعد تقارير اشارت الى انها
رفعت نسبه تخصيب اليورانيوم الى مستويات
تقترب من 90% وهو ما قد يمكنها من صناعه
القنبله الذريه
على كل المزيد من المتابع معي من باريس
الكاتب الصحفي ماجد الخطيب استاذ ماجد
اهلا وسهلا بك بدايه هنالك لغط كبير حول
نتائج السيد رفائيل جروسي الى طهران هل
كانت فاشله ام ناجحه يعني بدانا بالتفاؤل
ثم التشاؤم الان الحديث عن التشاؤل ما
رايه
بدايه تحيه طيبه لك وللساده المشاهدين
جميعا يعني اعتقد انه من غير المجدي الثقه
بايران فكما تفضلت في مقدمه هذا الخبر
هناك الكثير من الاحوال والاحداث حدثت في
السابق وتوقعنا باننا نحن في الدقيقه 90
وان ايران يعني باتت مستجيبه لمطالب
المجتمع الدولي وخاصه الدول الموقع على
يعني خمس اتفاق خمسه زائد واحد ثم ما لبث
بان ايران يعني تراجعت عن هذا الموضوع انا
اتصور بان ايران تحاول في كل مره يعني هذا
السيناريو يتكرر منذ عام 2018 بان ايران
تحاول ان تشتري الوقت هذا السيناريو يتكرر
الوكاله الدوليه تعرب عن ثقتها بان ايران
جاده الوكاله الدوليه الدوليه تقدم يعني
بعض التصريحات بان الامور تسير على على
خطى جيده وفي سبيل العوده الى العوده الى
الاتفاق وازاله كل العوائق ثم يعني ايران
تقوم ايضا بالرد ايجابي بشكل مماثل حتى
يمر وقت يعني انعقاد جلسه مجلس المحافظين
ثم بعد ذلك
تعود ايران الى العناد ووضع العصي
بالعجلات وبالتالي انا لا اتصور يعني بان
رافائيل روسي محق في هذا الافراط لانه هو
شخصيا قد تعرض لخيبه امل اكثر من مره في
ايران ثم دعنا نضيف نقطه في هذا السياق
مهمه جدا بان يعني ما هي طبيعه هذه ما هي
طبيعه هذه
الاتفاقيات التي تم التوصل اليها وان
ايران خاصه وان ايران وصلت الى حدود يعني
الحد العتبه النوويه ايران الان خصبت بحسب
اخر تقرير لوكاله الطاقه الذريه حوالي 84%
يعني هذا يعني بانها ايران بقي لها ان
تضغط على الزر على انتاج السلاح النووي
وبالتالي من الطبيعي ايران الان ان تراوغ
وان تحاول ان تبدي حسن النيه قبل اجتماعات
يوم غد والذي يليه المقابل
من اي استهداف للمنشات النوويه الايرانيه
سيدفع عسكري هو خط احمر دولي ما رايك
يعني نعم يعني انا اتصور بان رافائيل
جروسي لم يكن موفقا في هذه الاجابه يعني
رفع الجروسي وليس معنيا في تقييم يعني هذا
التصرف من النحو من الناحيه القانونيه لان
ببساطه اجيبك بان يعني بالقانون الدولي
وبحسب يعني الفصل السابع
الميثاق الامم المتحده عندما يستشعر مجلس
الامن الدولي بان هناك دوله ما تهدد الامن
والسلم الدولي تستطيع يعني دوله في من
مجلس الامن او مجلس الامن مجتمع بان يعني
يقوم بوضع حد بمهاجمه هذه الدوله ووضع حد
لاعاده السلم والامن الدوليين وبالتالي
انا اعتقد بان هذا الموضوع يجب احالته الى
مجلس الامن رافعيل الجروسي انا بتصوري
بانه حاول تلطيف الاجواء بين الغرب
والولايات المتحده من جهه وايران من جهه
ثانيه لذلك يعني استخدم هذه العباره وانما
انا بتصور لم يكن موفقا في استخدامها على
الاطلاق خاصه وان ايران الان يعني نستطيع
ان نقول اصبحت دوله يعني على عتبه نوويه
وبالتالي بالفعل هي قبل ان تمتلك السلاح
النووي سلوكها يهدد المنطقه منطقه الشرق
الاوسط الدول العربيه فما بالك سيدي
الفاضل عندما تمتلك هذا السلاح النووي هل
تراوغ وتكذب على مدى اكثر
من باريس الصحفي والكاتب السياسي ماجد
الخطيب شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاعر
ما زلنا في ايران لكن مع تطورات ازمه تسمم
الطالبات حيث افادت تقارير بالتعرض طالبات
في اربع مدارس جديده على الاقل للتسمم في
محافظه زنجان الايرانيه من جانبها اقرت
السلطات بانتشار الاصابات في اكثر من
خمسين مدرسه اخرى
[موسيقى]
وفي محاوله لتهدئه الغضب الشعبي جراء
الازمه قال وزير التعليم الايراني يوسف
نوري ان التحقيقات لا تزال جاريه في حوادث
التسمم واضاف المسؤول الايراني ان
التحقيقات لم تصل حتى الان لاي نتيجه حول
الجهه المتورطه في هذا الحادث مشيرا الى
ان التعليم عن بعد لم تتم مناقشته الى ذلك
اكد المتحدث باسم الحكومه انه سيتم تقديم
المسؤولين عن حالات التسمم الى العداله
لمحاسبته
[موسيقى]
بحث الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي مع
رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شريعه السوداني
في القاهره العلاقات الثنائيه وسبل
توطيدها من الرئيس المصري عن رغبه مصر
واستعدادها للتعاون مع العراق في مختلف
المجالات وبحسب بيان لمكتب السوداني تمت
مناقشه القضايا الاقليميه والدوليه ذات
الاهتمام المشترك مع بحث تفعيل اللجان
المشتركه بما يقوي الشراكه بين البلدين
نشط الخامسه مستمره في ايضا
القتال يشتعل مجددا بين ارمينيا واذربيجان
مقتل ثلاثه جنود ارمينيين في ناغورنو
كارابا
اهلا بكم من جديد مناطق شمال شرق سوريا لا
تغيبوا ابدا عن اعين تركيا والتي بدات
بالسيطره على مناطق عده غربا بدعم من
فصائل المعارضه ثم زحفت شرقا حتى اوقفتها
منطقه عين العرب التي منعت التواصل
الجغرافي بين مناطق سيطره المعارضه شرقا
وغرب الفرات العربيه تمكنت من الوصول الى
منبج المجاوره لعين العرب والتي كانت ضمن
ثلاث مناطق تشملها التهديدات العسكريه
التركيه
فهناك رصدنا خريطه النفوذ المعقده ووصلنا
الى خط المواجهه الاخير الذي تتواجد فيه
القوات النظاميه السوريه
[موسيقى]
طريق ينثر على اطراف الفاعلون في الملف
السوري نقاطهم الامنيه المتقاربه فمعادره
الامن هنا دقيقه ومعقده هذه مناطق محاذيه
لتركيا تسيطر عليها قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه قوات كرديه تتهمها انقره
بتهديد امنها وبربط علاقات مع حزب العمال
كردستانيه لذا ترفض اقترابها من الحدود
وتراقب تحركاتها جوا كما تضربها بين الحين
والاخر
وتهددها بعمل بري كبير
التهديدات التركيه بشان عمليه عسكريه في
شمال شرق سوريا متواصله الهدف المعلن
اقامه منطقه امنه بعمق 30 كيلومتر ولتحقيق
هذا المسعى تخطط القوات التركيه والفصائل
المواليه لها الدخول الى منبج والى كوباني
المجاوره وترفعه ما يعني عمليا شريطا
حدوديا خاضعا لتركيا من ادلب الى حدود
قامشلي
شريط يقطع اوصال منطقه كرديه ممتده في
المنطقه تعيد اليه تركيا اللاجئين
السوريين
تحاول ربط مناطق التي تحتلها في منطقه
الابيض
وجرابلس كل هذه الامور انا ما نجمعها
بدا حمله عسكريه هناك لكن ليس مرتبطه في
وقت رفعت ايضا نحن ناخذ هذه التهديدات
بشكل جدي ونتعامل معها بشكل جدي
[موسيقى]
خطه تجعل قسل بحاجه الى هذه النقاط التي
نمر على مقربه منها
المعركه في منبج وكوباني وترفعت مختلفه
تخضع لخارطه النفوذ فمثلا حيث اقف الان
خلفي موقعا عسكريا تابع للنظام من المفترض
ان يكون هذا الموقع بالاضافه الى مواقع
اخرى تابعه للنظام خط المواجهه الاول مع
القوات التركيه والفصائل المواليه لانقره
في حال قررت التقدم ودخول منبج لكن حسابات
السياسه وتجارب السابقه قد تفرض واقعا
مختلفا في حال قررت دمشق اتخاذ موقف
الحياد
موقف حياد لا تتمناه قصد لكنها ترى بعض
مؤشراته حتى الان مواقف خجوله وتحركاتهم
ايضا خجوله وتحضيراتهم ايضا خجوله لكن
لديهم تواجد ونحن نامل يكونوا يشاركوا
معنا في المعركه ان حصلت هل هناك
اتفاق برعايه روسيه الانتشار حرس الحدود
التابع لقوات حكومه دمشق هذه القوات
الموجوده حتى الان في الاونه الاخيره ليس
هدف قبل الاشهر كان هناك زياده عدد القوات
وهم متواجدون فبالتاكيد نحن كقوات نؤكد ان
القوات المتواجده على خطوط التماسك مع
الجانب التركي هي قوات حرس الحدود التابعه
النظام مع
تدابير لنا
سياسيا ايضا يرصد الاكراد انعطافه في
علاقه دمشق وانقره تثير مخاوفهم اي
التقارب بين الطرفين سيكون على حساب
الاداره الذاتيه وعلى اساءاع على حساب
الشعب السوري وعلى حساب قوات سوريا الديمق
هذا يعني في نقاط هذا هذه النقاط المشتركه
بين
هذين النظامين
اكيد كان هناك اتفاقيه اضنه موجوده يعني
بين الطرفين سيكون تجديد لهذه الاتفاقيه
روسيا التي تراقب المشهد من نقاطها
الامنيه هنا تعمل على تخفيض اي توتر يقوض
سياده حليفها النظام ترفض عملا عسكريا
للاطراك لكنها تعقد اتفاقيات لتسيير
دوريات مشتركه معهم كل هذا فيما تعزز
وجودها قرب الامريكيين المعنيين اولا
بالحرب على داعش صار بنعيشوبه العربيه من
شمال شرق سوريا
وفي سوريا ايضا دانت وزاره الخارجيه زياره
رئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه الامريكي مارك
ميلي الى شمال شرق سوريا ووصفت دمشق
الزياره بغير القانونيه معتبره انها
انتهاك صارخ لسياده ووحده البلاد
في تركيا يجتمع زعماء تحالف المعارضه غدا
للاعلان رسميا عن المرشح المشترك
للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقرر لها فيما
المقبل لكن الامر ليس بهذه السهوله فمعنى
الانقسامات التي ضربت التحالف بقي خمسه
زعماء في التحالف السداسي حيث جددوا
التزامهم بمبادئ الائتلاف التاسيسيه في
محاوله لاظهار راس الصدى زعيم المعارضه
التركيه ورئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري التركي
كليتش دار اوغلو قال انه ما من فسحه في
التحالف للالعاب السياسيه مشيرا الى ان
المزيد من الاحزاب قد تنضم للتكتل وذلك
ردا على انسحاب حزب الخير ثاني اكبر حزب
في تحالف المعارضه
في المقابل وردا على انقسام تحالف
المعارضه قال اردوغان ان حزب العداله
والتنميه الحاكم وحليفه القومي يتمسكان
بمواصله مسارهما متهما احزاب المعارضه
للبحث عن مصالحها الخاصه
انقسام المعارضه يصب في مصلحه اردوغان
الذي شهدت شعبيته تراجعا حتى قبل وقوع
زلزال الشهر الماضي الذي اودى بحياه ما
يقرب من 46 الف شخص وسط ازمه غلاء المعيشه
في تركيا
خلافات ائتلاف المعارضه التركي زعيمه حزب
الخير ميرال اكشنر تنسحب من تكتمل الطويله
السداسيه في الخطوه العامقه الازمه قبل
اسابيع من الانتخابات الرئاسيه
اكشنر اتهمت اعضاء التحالف بالضغط على
حزبها وتحدي اراده الشعب اقتراحات اكشن
ترشيح رئيس بلديه انقره منصور يابش او
رئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرام
وكلاهما من حزب الشعب الجمهوري
[موسيقى]
حزب الشعب الجمهوري له قاعده التصويت
الاكبر في التحالف لديه حزب الخير الذي
يعد الثاني اكبر حزب في تحالف المعارضه
تركيا السيد زاهد اهلا وسهلا بك الى عماده
المعارضه في تركيا مشتته مضعضعه كثير ام
لا هذا الكلام غير دقيق وغير صحيح
يعني بدايه من المؤكد ان المعارضه نحن لا
نتحدث عن توجه سياسي واحد بل نتحدث عن
مجموعه احزاب وايديولوجيات مختلفه
وبالتالي
لا يمكن الحديث ان هناك معارضه موحده لكن
الذي حصل منذ خمس سنوات تقريبا ان هناك
التحالفات قد نشات بسبب الظروف السياسيه
التي فرضتها النظام الرئاسي من جهه وكذلك
الالاعيب السياسيه التي فرضها اردوغان من
جهه اخرى في تحديد موعد الانتخابات في
اكثر من مره مما اضطر حزب الشعب الجمهوري
الى ان يقدم بعض نوابه كنوع من انواع يعني
جعل حزب الخير او حزب الحزب الجيد الدخول
لادخاله لحمله الانتخابات او لادخال
الانتخابات التي كان سيحرم منها لولا هذه
الخطوه مثل هذه التحالفات حقيقه بدات واتت
اكلها حقيقه في انتخابات البلديه السابق
نحن نتحدث عن انتصارات حقيقيه
للمعارضه وسيطره من المعارضه واحزابها على
غالبيه بلديات تركيا السبب في ذلك
والتحالف الذي نشا بشكل عملي وبشكل واقعي
اليوم حقيقه كان المامول بطبيعه الحال ان
يكون هناك رؤيه متفق عليها اعتقد ان
الرؤيه متفق عليها بين كل الاحزاب
المعارضه لا يوجد فيها خلاف في اطار
الرؤيه الخلاف فقط حسب المعطيات الان على
المرشح
اذا استطعت هل هذا هل هذا الخلاف هل هذا
الخلاف استاذ زاهد يصب في مصلحه الرئيس
اردوغان وفي مصلحه حزب العداله والتنميه
بتعرف كانت التحليلات تذهب الى انه يعني
نتائج الزلزال الكارثي
سيهدد مستقبل اردوغان وحزب العداله
والتنميه السياسيا الان
كانه يقال انه حسابات الحقل غير حسابات
البيده
يعني ابتداء من المؤكد ان
هذه الخلافات التي لطفت الى السطح قبل
يومين اثنين من المؤكد انها اثرت لا اقول
فقط في الشارع المعارض وانما اثرت في كل
تركيا يعني نحن كاتراك وانتهاء
لم يمر حقيقه على اكبر كارثه حلت بنا شهر
ونتحدث الان عن زلزال حقيقي في السياسه
يعني من المؤكد ان الحديث في هذا الموضوع
في هذا التوقيت وبهذه الصيغه هو نوع من
انواع العبث اكثر منه واقعيه سياسيه
وبالتالي من المؤكد ان هذه الخلافات
وطريقه معالجتها الان بعيده كل البعد عن
الواقعيه السياسيه وهو امر من المؤكد انه
سيؤثر على نفسيه الناخبين التي لا يمكن في
رايي الشخصي حتى هذه اللحظه دراستها لاننا
نتحدث عن وقائع اجتماعيه تغيرت خلال 25
يوما الماضيه ونتحدث عن غضب حقيقي في
التركي تجاه المؤسسه السياسيه عموما مما
يؤكد ربما على عزوف ربما الكثير من
الناخبين عن العمليه السياسيه لاول مره
بهذه الصيغه
طبعا لا اريد ان استبق الاحداث لكن بشكل
عام الانقسام السياسي كما كان حاصلا قبل
الزلزال واقع بالفعل
والمامول حقيقه من السياسيين الاتراك سواء
كانوا في الحكومه او المعارضه ان يقدموا
للشارع التركي ما يريده من خطاب بعيدا عن
المغناكفات السياسيه التي نشهدها الان من
اسطنبول رئيس تحرير تركيا زاهد جول شكرا
جزيلا على هذه المشاركه
[موسيقى]
وفي تداعيات زلزال تركي حذر مختصون اتراك
من حدوث تغير تغير ديموغرافي كبير في
البلاد بسبب موجات النزوح لعشرات الالاف
من ضحايا الزلزال وفيما يفضل البعض الفرار
من الولايات الجنوبيه المتضرره نحو مدن
وسط وشمال تركيا شهدت كثير من القرى كذلك
هجره عكسيه للباحثين عن الامام
هذه المشاهد تتكرر يوميا خلال اولى ساعات
الصباحات انطاكيا المنكوبه فرار جماعي
للناجين من الزلزال الذي جعلها تاي من
اكبر المدن التضررا منهم من يملك وجهه
محدده ومنهم من سيحددها لاحقا خلال ساعات
الرحله الطويله بحثا عن الامان يعني
[موسيقى]
رفقاتي منهم ماتوا منهم راحوا لله الامر
بس
[موسيقى]
كل جيراني في هذه البنايه والحي غادروا
الى مدن اخرى انا كذلك تقرر هدم بيت
المتصدع وساذهب الى انقره واعيش هناك عند
اقاربه
كما السوريين الذين الف الترحاله دخل
الاتراك كذلك في هجره داخليه الى مدن
الشمال وعكسيه اعادت المئات منهم الى
القرى هنا بقريه جولباش بضواحيها تاي
ياملون النجاه بانفسهم من الزلزال وهزاته
المتتاليه لكن هذه السيده لا تامن الوضع
وتفضل الخيمه على البقاء داخل بيتها
منذ حدوث زلزال عدنا الى قرانه التي اصبحت
مزدحمه هي الاخرى هنا الوضع اقل خطوره من
مركز هاتاي لكني اخاف البقاء في البيت
لذلك انا في الخيمه
اما هذا الرجل فوجد نفسه لاجئا في خيمه
حتى وهو يعود الى قريته التي غادرها قبل
خمسه عقود من الاربعه وسبعين لها اليوم
فهذا من القريه بعيد
وهسه
رجعنا على مكان الاول باركين بالخيام مع
الندور ما عندنا شيء وفقا للارقام الرسميه
فقد عاد اكثر من اربعين الف سوري طواعيه
الى سوريا فيما لم يتم الكشف بعد عن اعداد
المنكوبين من الاتراك وغيرهم ممن نزحوا
مدن تركيه اخرى
تطمينات السلطات التركيه
باعاد ضريره سريعا لم توقف موجات النزوح
لعشرات الالاف من المنكوبين ما يؤشر الى
حدوث تغير ديموغرافي قد يزيد من متاعب
الحكومه في معالجه اثار الزلزال عبد
القادر خربوش العربيه
في اليونان طلب رئيس الوزراء اليوناني
كرياكوس
الصفح من اسر ضحايا كارثه القطار التي
اوجدت بحياه سبعه وخمسين شخصا كما تعهد
بعدم تكرار مثل هذه الحوادث في البلاد
في هذه الاثناء يبدو ان الغضب لم يتوقف
للحظه في اعقاب حادث تصادم القطارين حيث
وقعت مواجهات عنيفه في اثينا بين الشرطه
والمتظاهرين احتجاجا على الحادث ياتي ذلك
بالتزامن مع ادلاء مدير محطه السكك الحديد
الذي اعترف بمسؤوليته عن كارثه القطار
امام القضاء اليوناني
ويفترض ويفترض ان يبث قاضي التحقيق في
لاريسا وهي اقرب بلده الى مكان الحادث في
نهايه الجلسه فيما اذا كان سيتهمه بالقتل
الخطا عبر الاهمال في خطوه تعتبر تمهيدا
لاجراءات جنائيه محتمله ضد اداره شركه
السكك الحديد هل
قالت صحف محليه يونانيه ان القضاء يسعى
الى فهم كيف وجد مدير محطه عديم الخبره
نفسه بمفرده بدون اشراف اي شخص اخر في
محطه لاريسا لمده اربعه ايام عندما كانت
حركه السكك الحديد على هذا الخط شديده
بسبب عطله نهايه الاسبوع
ويطالب الشباب اليوناني بالحقيقه على
الرغم من اعتراف الحكومه بمسؤوليتها عن
المشاكل المزمنه لشبكه السكك الحديد التي
ادت الى وقوع هذا الحاجز
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الى اثنا لمزيد من المتابعه لهذا الموضوع
ينضم الي من هناك الدكتور عبد اللطيف
درويش وهو استاذ الاقتصاد واداره الازمات
بجامعه كاردف متروبوليتان دكتور عبد
اللطيف اهلا وسهلا بك هل حكومه السيد
ميستوتاكس في خطر وهل سيضحي السيد
ميسوتاكس بعدد من وزرائه لاحتواء الازمه
ام لا الامور لن تذهب الى هذا الحد
اعتقد طبعا اكيد تعرفون ان استقال طبعا
وزير المواصلات الان هناك اعتقال لشخصين
الشخصين الذين كان ليله المناوبه ومدير
الشركه وهي شركه خاصه اعتقد الحكومه نعم
ما انهدات عمليه الفضيحه التجسس من خلال
مخابرات اليونانيه على زعماء المعارضه
ومتابعتهم وخاصه زعيم الحزب الاشتراكي
وكانت هناك مسؤوليات جنائيه على الحكومه
لانه تتعارض مع الدستور اليوناني وهو ايضا
عضو في البرلمان الاوروبي حتى ايضا تاتي
الفضيحه هذه من خلال ضعف الاداء الحكومه
في متابعه الشركه الخاصه التي يدفع لها من
دافعي الضرائب اليونان 50 مليون في السنه
لعمليه اداره السكك الحديديه وهي تابعه
للدوله فبالتالي كان هناك عمليه ضعف طبعا
الشركه حتى توفر على نفسها لم تكن يعني
تعين موظفين ذكاءه او العدد المطلوب من
المو وايضا هناك تم شراء او تزويد هذه
المؤسسه بان 2003 باجهزه الكترونيه متابعه
من خلال الرادار لحركه القطارات والتي لم
تستعمل على الاطلاق فبالتالي هناك ضعف
الاداء الحكومي دفع الوزير الاول واعتقد
ان الحكومه ستدفع الثمن في الانتخابات
القادمه ونحن على مسافه الانتخابات هل
نتوقع طيب من الان وحتى الانتخابات القادم
في حال استمرت هذه التظاهرات الاحتجاجيه
هل من المرجح هل السيناريو استقاله
الحكومه برمتها مطروح وهل يكفي انه السيد
مشوتاكسي يطلب من الشعب الصفح يعني هل
الصفح كافي برايك
لا اعتقد لان ايضا المعارضه تصعد من
الموقف لانها فرصه لها حدث وطبعا هما
حاولوا يعني يحملوا الحكومات السابقه وهذه
وهذا هراء اعتقد اذا استمرت الاضرابات
لانه ايضا هناك اضراب في المواصلات
اليونانيه من يوم الى اخر هناك طبعا كما
تعرفون حاله احتقان جدا كبيره في الشارع
الاوروبي وفي الشارع اليوناني على الاوضاع
المعيشه نتيجه الحرب الاوكرانيه وضعف قدره
الشرائيه فاعتقد الان هناك تنفيس من قبل
المواطنين في هذا الموضوع واذا استمرت
طبعا الدامن الحكومات الينا اذا واجهت
ازمه من هذا النوع تستقيل
من اثنى الدكتور عبد اللطيف درويش استاذ
الاقتصاد واداره الازمات بجامعه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
افادت وسائل الاعلام ارمينيه بمقتل ثلاثه
جنود ارمينيين في الشباك مع قوات
اذربيجانيه في ناغورنو كاراباخ بدورها
اكلت اذربيجان وقوعه خسائر بشريه في جيشها
جراء الاشتباكات مع القوات الارمينيه
مشيره الى استمرار الاشتباكات في محور
ناغورنو كارابا
من جانبها دعت الخارجيه الارمينيه الى
ارسال بعثه مراقبه دوليه الى المنطقه بعد
الشباكات اليوم
وافق اعضاء الامم المتحده للمره الاولى
على اول معاهده لحمايه التنوع البيولوجي
في اعالي البحار وهي المساحه التي تمثل ما
يقرب بالنصف سطح الكوكب وذلك عقب اسبوعين
من المحادثات في نيويورك
وتدعم المعاهده الى انفاذ تعهد مؤتمر
الامم المتحده للتنوع البيولوجي بحمايه
30% من محيطات الكوكب
وتحدد القواعد الاساسيه لاجراء تقييمات
الاثر البيئي للانشطه التجاريه في
المحيطات
هذا ووصف المفوضيه الاوروبيه القرار بانه
لحظه تاريخيه وخطوه حاسمه للحفاظ على
الحياه البحريه
والتنوع البيولوجي
في العالم
نشاط الخامسه انتهت قبل التحيات والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]